calme vérifie l'état de conscience
demander de l'aide
rien les voies respiratoires en cas de
malaise cardiaque
les défibrillateurs font partie des
trois gestes qui sauvent la commune de
plaisir a décidé d'en installer 11 dans
des lieux publics comme la mairie annexe
le palais des sports ou encore le
château c'est quelque chose qui manquait
à la ville bien évidemment oui c'est
indispensable aujourd'hui si on veut
effectivement assurer la gérer la
tranquillité une certaine tranquillité
dans les chances de survie ne sont pas
toujours 100% mais d'une tranquillité de
l'ensemble des personnes qui pour
l'ensemble des personnes qui fréquentent
ces lieux publics plaisir a souhaité
former en premier lieu des élus sur la
base du volontariat
les employés municipaux seront eux aussi
sensibilisés depuis mai 2007 toute
personne même non médecin est autorisé à
utiliser un défibrillateur automatisé
externe et fonctionne sur le même modèle
alors la seule variante est temps que
certains vont aussi vous proposer de
lancer le choc tout seul donc vous dire
attention analyses en cours choc
recommandé eloignez-vous 3 2 1 est il en
ce choc tout seul donc on a ces deux
possibilités en france à voir les
défibrillateurs entièrement automatiques
ou semi-automatique semi automatique
c'est quand on appuie sur le bouton
d'ici les mois de septembre octobre deux
véhicules de patrouille de la police
municipale seront à leur tour équipés de
défibrillateurs la commune ya consacré
un budget de 15 mille cinq cents euros